I Kip.
My Kip.
Hey, Brian. Hey, Sarah, how are you?
Do well.
Doing well, how are you?
I'm doing good. Good.
Good.
How's your weather? Is it very hot?
So, how's it going?
It's very hot. It's really very hot. So around, it's above 100 degrees Fahrenheit.
Oh wow, that is hot.
Yeah.
Yeah, it squared off.
So, yeah, it is what it is, so I'm dealing with it.
Yeah.
And, yeah, how are things going there?
I'd say they're going pretty well.
Yeah, busy, busy, but good.
And how's modern doing?
Excellent, as always.
Any feedback, any suggestions, anything to share?
Nothing outside what the normal feedback is, Kip, so...
Okay.
Key.
Okay, all right. So let's quickly jump into the presentation then.
All right.
Let me share my screen real quick.
Are you able to see my screen?
You got it.
Yes.
Okay, great. So, welcome to our monthly business review, and this is starting 4th May till 29th May. We had our quarterly business review on 5th, so I included that week as well for the review.
So moving on to the agenda, it's the same check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
And we already talked about how things are going and.
There are no any feedbacks to share for Warren, so things are moving in our direction.
And in the highlights, we have been...
receiving positive feedback over, consistent in delivery and responsiveness. And we already discussed about the shadowing initiative or the project work.
In this, do have we made any progress on that one point?
No, not really.
Okay.
And...
Okay, and we also discussed about the KPI targets, utilization target retained at 80%. And the CSAT survey for the month of June, I believe has already been sent out.
So just keep an eye on your inbox once you get it. Take out some time to put that out for one.
Okay.
Yeah, I don't believe I've seen it, but I'll double check.
Okay, yeah, he it'll be out maybe today or anytime this week, so...
And this is the action tracker. So we are tracking his training and certification on MDE 102. We were expecting him to finish it by 30th April, but we are, I'm connecting with him on a bi-weekly basis to track the progress and creating milestones.
And he is making progress. He's working on scheduling his exam within this month.
And these were the KPIs we discussed. I'm going to skip this for now.
Let's jump into the performance analysis. This is his utilization for the last four weeks. Average utilization had been around 40%. Started with low in the month of May, but then showed an upward trend.
Move to 46, 49, and then back to 40.
and primarily working on the onboarding, onboarding tickets, application issues mostly.
And are we expecting any more bulk or are we onboarding more customers, clients?
We do have two customers that have just been brought on, and we also shifted two of our customers off of the tier one support. We have a company that kind of does like tier one support triage and stuff like that for 24-7 customers, and two customers that aren't 24-7 came back to internal.
to our internal support team. So there's going to be a slight bump in work there. One of those has already been brought in, and the second one, I think, is it has been brought in as of the beginning of this month. So I don't foresee a large uptick in utilization because of that Kip, but there might be something small to kind of increase that. But I would say the utilization for Varun is kind of consistent with the team.
Oh.
Mmhmm.
Okay.
the other team members. There is available bandwidth for more work. So we're aware of that. And I've been somewhat promoting the idea of going to get more customers, right? But sometimes those are hard to find. So.
Yeah.
Yeah, I completely understand. No problem, Ryan. Do let us know in case you need any help from our side, and we will be more than happy to help.
Okay.
And feel free to engage him wherever you seem he's fit.
like documentation part, creating SOPs or automation scripting.
So, yeah.
This is his ticket data for these four weeks. So the ticket closure had always been more than 100%. And he worked on 118 tickets and closed 124.
Any question on this one, Ryan?
Not at this time.
Key.
So way forward, as we discussed just now, absorb available bandwidth with proactive and project-based bulk, like creating SOPs, documentation part.
And yeah, we are targeting 60% around or plus utilization by the end of quarter two. And as I mentioned earlier as well, we are tracking Varun's CDP, which is training and certification on MDE one or two. So I will be helping him out on
completing this by the end of this month.
And these are the some AI by design initiatives by IT by design, which you are already aware. I'm going to skip this. And this is the team GPS, our in-house built-in tool. Let's skip this.
So, that's it. Anything additional you want to share on?
Feel free.
Just that he's been a valuable asset to the team, and I appreciate everything he does, so...
Yes, agreed.
Yeah, thank you. Anything apart?
Does he, I was just going to say too, Kip, the feedback you get from him, is he still happy with the work he's doing here or is he hungry for more?
He is happy and he is hungry for more, so it's both.
Haha.
Yeah.
Yeah, so...
All right.
So, that's why I said, so feel free to engage him wherever you feel like he's a fit, and in case in terms of trainings.
or any study material, we are here to help.
Be it another technology or another skill set, so no problem with that.
Got it.
He got all the help required from the ITBD site.
Sounds good.
Yeah. All right. So I guess that was a quick call. So thank you for joining this morning. And yeah, we don't have to wait for these calls. So in case you have anything to share or suggest, feel free to email me anytime. And then I would be more than happy to respond.
Yeah, short and sweet.
Will do.
Thank you, Sarah. Thank you, Brian.
I appreciate that, and then if you need anything from us, just let us know.
Sure, I will. Thank you. Bye-bye.
Okay.
See you Kip.
Bye.